we're going to start off with Phoenix
Arizona
Inez is calling or in this how are you
I'm pretty good I got papers yesterday
from Social Security like 16 pages so I
guess all that out today oh good yeah it
said the 14th is when they mailed it out
and I have ten days to get it in and I
got it yesterday so that narrows down my
days there but my my problem is and I
don't know if you heard but I'm a
disability from the post office a
federal job they don't pay for
disability like even temporary
disability so I'm gonna wait seven eight
months for that to go through and see if
I offend approved for disability in the
meantime I well before I went on
disability I had bought a car so there
was just a year ago I bought this car
because I put 80 some miles on my car
every day going back to forth to work so
I thought this I need it I need
something dependable to get back to
Forth Worth so I bought it well I didn't
realize how they roll over your amount
it from your other car onto that one and
so my payment was like six fifty four
and then when I get my I look at my
receipt and all that when I got home I
was like okay now the cars like $37,000
pay off on it compared to most a
brand-new car like that is about twenty
five thousand so I said man this doesn't
look good you know
after I'm going through disability and
thinking how can I pay for this car keep
paying for it when I don't have anything
coming in except for a private
disability I took out myself with just
only like a thousand dollars a month so
I'm basically just paying my utilities
with a thousand dollars you know and and
then I also when I found out that Tia
fine house was going to take my car they
called me a threaten and they said we're
gonna come and take it and they said I
just can't right now pay you anything
you know so I did pay them a hundred
dollars they accepted that and but they
keep calling me wanting the car
and I thought I'm gonna do without a car
completely and I gotta get back and
forth to my doctor's appointment so I
went and bought one on side the road a
used car so I do have that but they are
saying regret taking my car and then I
have to pay the difference between the
chaos and what they're going to put in
auction and get for it so I'm friend of
Mines like well you have to file
bankruptcy to get rid of that mm-hm
I'm just trying to hold out because I
don't want to file bankruptcy I've been
there before in fact during the housing
problems my husband's deceased now we
lost our homes because they said well
you have to file bankruptcy which you
know then they came back out said no but
they said you have to or your response
for that difference okay so let's talk
stop okay okay if you're receiving pry
if you're receiving disability income
only that cannot be confiscated by a
lawsuit that's Social Security
disability correct and your disability
as well from the post office if you've
got private a private disability payment
that you're receiving neither one of
those can be garnished okay so if they
take the car and they will come after
you for the difference and you're not
able to work out anything on the
difference there is no requirement for
you to file bankruptcy because they
can't take your income okay you're what
we call judgment proof because you're so
broke that you don't have anything for
them to get they can't get at your
disability income and you don't have
anything else I assume right well just
my retirement you know from the post
that's not rejected as well do you have
any other money or any other assets do
you own a paid-for home do you have a
big pile of money in a bank or in
another investment no I went through
basically everything and then my you
know with my husband passing away I'm on
my own so I don't have a home the only
other thing I have is this car that I
like I said to you there it's a beater
they don't want it so let's pretend that
they take the car because that's what's
going to happen you simply cannot pay a
$600
car payment right there's not any
there's not anything that's gonna happen
to keep this car from going away so when
you get off the phone call them and tell
them to come get it okay because they're
either gonna take it okay they want it
already they're just trying to figure
out where it is and then when they take
it yes they're gonna sell it at auction
and yes they're going to come to you for
the difference if they come to you
asking for $16,000 they might as well
ask you for two hundred thousand right
right cause you don't have it so then
you're gonna have to negotiate at some
point in the future when you get some
money built up you could call them and
say I don't have sixteen thousand but I
got four thousand and I'd like to settle
this and you'll settle the debt later
you're not bankrupt though so you're
getting bad advice on them from your
friend who doesn't know what they're
talking about just not somebody you need
to take financial advice from you're not
bankrupt bankruptcy is you know dropping
an atom bomb on a on an ant
at this point it's just not necessary
something needed so um that that's you
know I'm really sorry you're facing all
this as hard times for you but you're
gonna lose the car you should have never
bought the car from day one you should
have never left the lot without looking
at those pieces of paper and handing
them those keys back and going I'm not
doing this and you know and you know
that you know that was really ugly dumb
move a six hundred dollar car payment in
your life in no time in no place in
history would that been anything but
crazy right and so you just you you've
just a mistake you may we all make
mistakes no there's no excuse there's no
it's good no there's no excuse we don't
think right when we go through the dust
and all that my mine wasn't there yeah
you're right and you got screwed because
of it yeah so you got to go slow while
you're facing this disability and slow
when you're making these other decisions
because you really can't afford two or
three or more of these decisions like
this no I'll tell you what hold on I'm
gonna have Kelly pick up I'm gonna have
one of our financial coaches that has
been through our training help you as my
gift to make sure that you make this
this situation be minimized and make
sure that they unpack with you your
whole situation and that that what I'm
telling you is right
because I think I'm right if I've got
all the picture I'm right but I'm a
little bit afraid that there might be a
little corner of this that I'm not
seeing yet so I want someone to sit down
with you and help you and I'm gonna pay
for it okay so you hold on and I'll have
Kelly pick up we'll have one of our Dave
Ramsey financial coaches meet with you
there in Phoenix and look at this
situation with you you're not bankrupt
don't go file bankruptcy but I think you
are gonna lose this car so hold on I'll
get you some help kiddo and move slow
and careful you do not have room to make
more errors like this ouch
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that your broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you